fatta una legge si rifà
tutte cose che facciamo questo suono
occhio al rombo di tuono
tema di domanda era ferito
ciao ragazzi benvenuti a una puntata di
vita buttata oggi mi farò un tè con
cecilia cantarano ma grazie per essere
venuto da dove devo guardare lavorato a
quella per se vuoi parlare in macchina
lì poi diciamo guardare un pochino tutti
quanti noi
rubate fatti parla con me ogni tanto poi
capito ammiccare
sono negli anni 90 che hanno sai 2006
leggere come questa generazione del dopo
il 1999 mortificante
polvere che posso offrire qualcosina
morto
così
un 2 3 4 5 6 6
siamo pronti per una puntata di vita
buttana
[Musica]
sono un cane membri sono e cafone è solo
un cafone una zolletta la volete solo
roma
alessandro allora parliamone un secondo
sandro per la prima volta a vita buttata
portiamo una ventata di giovinezza
possiamo dirlo perché tendenzialmente a
next unamuno giusto cosa cioè
avvicinate banco tecnopatia capito io mi
trovo questo è il fascino del 2000
e ciano ospite la fa un breve
da premettere il neo 17 anni in questa
relazione di quattro anni che è stata
piena di tradimenti da parte sua litigi
molto tossica come relazione ad esso
attualmente come ci vediamo presenza
stare insieme il fatto è che il
consiglio che vorrei è come faccio a un
tiro di corrette al cuore a cannes non
so se è termine scientifico termini
numero giusto devi lasciar stare devi
allontanarti cioè 17 anni tuttavia
davanti che vivono a 22 sono vecchi
da un lato saggezza di 22 anni di vita
nessun'altra cosa ci fa questo qui se ne
[ __ ] al motto no che cosa succede
quindi in questo caso che da una parte
secondo me lei potrebbe avere un
attaccamento di quel tipo ma
l'attaccamento vero è uno che con una
persona tossica nel momento in cui tu la
molli non sai più chi sei perché se non
hai qualcuno che ti critica ogni due
secondi e chi lo farà quando poi non c'è
per lui ciao ciao sfide
comunque la mia mamma e situazione più
non tanto dentro consumato mi segue mi
madre
è come un padre allora facciamo così
andate avanti muti perché sono siete
morbosi di confronti vostra figlia
saranno case un accanimento
ma solo riempì ragazzi ciascuna dozza
avevo molte cose dell'ordine mentre ed
ero giovane
26 anni 25
a 26 22
farà freddo a dritta io ti do un
biglietto gratis e fece essere mamma con
il mio ragazzo ciric nomen camera ma non
potevo chiudere la porta quindi cosa
facevo dovevo trovare un modo
alternativo e il modo alternativo si
chiamava gatto sulla tangenziale io
chiudevo la porta spegne tutte le luci e
prendevo una lampada che sparava contro
la porta in modo che se tu a brini
avevano trattare il falo di innocenti a
chicago e quindi non vedevi che cosa
succederà nelle ombre e poi appena ti
riprende lo siamo noi tranquilli che
stava guardando un film ma per due
secondi prima io stavo proprio
tutte cose facciano questo suono poi mi
sono tranquillo la sala fidanzata
soffiata sette anni ceco due ragazze
diaz mente però sempre sarà rialzata con
due ragazzi mai situazioni imbarazzanti
me niente ancora
qualcosa
a verità tutti gli altri mi auguro
ospite orti di voi avevate un consiglio
a livello sentimentale secondo voi è
visto male che magari un ragazzo 24 anni
si lamentano una ragazza di 18
macché veramente ho 18 anni mi piace
noah 11 che dice una ragazzina rapita
dai presa da fuori dai media dei capi ma
possiamo anche quando ci piace un
qualcosa o qualcuno e a quest altra
persona piacciamo farci problemi di
quello che pensa tizio caio e sempronio
cioè difficile che ci piaccia qualcosa
al 2 pure pensare che quella stessa cosa
mi piace a tutti gli altri che ci stanno
attorno che palle che sei a differenza
11 17 c'è un problema risolto sei un ma
la vera mente va a curare io ho
frequentato per un periodo quella
persona
addirittura nel nodo poi alla fine non è
andata poi poi succede a tutti gli altri
c'era tutti chiamati 6 a differenza come
loro per tre
io so che tu hai una passione
qual è il tuo hobby che tu dici per me
fare questa cosa è bellissimo video
cantare uscire di galera per questo non
ti fermo fare tutto questo sito a questo
punto direi di lanciare il seguito
quello che noi faremo adesso è sfidarci
ok sfida dovremmo disegnare quello che
leggiamo le categorie sono viaggi perle
di saggezza e cine come nel caso per
l'eccezionale insomma dall'inizio questa
è una persona coi piedi e cia in mano
ovvio che un trapano un monociclo sakuma
si sta facendo sta provando si sta
facendo di sostanze facendo fare
faccio fi fatto non
fatto fatta fatta fatta una bilancia
legge fatta legge fatta una legge se ne
va
fatta la legge 100 trovato cerca trovato
trova però fatta dc trovato basta fatta
la legge trovato l'inganno
rieti una perla non spero che sia
difficile in culo di voglio sparare
rifai che cos'è una persona o allora
l'uomo si ma gli stipendi segna però ha
capito ci stava di spiegarmi bene
racconta sto cazzo fatto vieni qui a
fare quello che vuoi
potete roreto sto cazzo
ma certo la legge primo sottolinea resto
gas divieto chi divieto a chi chi non
mi ha descritto n è una che non scrive
mette tutti i verbi che tu perché stai
parlando esattamente è una cosa di c'è
tipo di riparo da buttare io non so da
chi non sembra
mamma mi questa di spalle con una cena
risso perché
se tu non avessi mi ha detto che è il
nasino all'insù di non avrei mai capito
che era un essere umano chi non sa
insegna
scusami ma questi cibi che sono sono
piatti che esistono davvero e in gambero
salottino gambero gambe dicano gli occhi
così come il punto tavola grazie a un
bagnato anch'io a un restante ti
ringrazio una birra camera la birra bere
alcol alcolista e sta briaco ubriaco
gambe ubriaco cioè per rende conto oltre
a posto ma ti rendi conto gambero
bricola to veramente cioè di problema
i baffi neri non vuoi provare un viaggio
in una pistola che c'hai
barca arca titanic porto bravo però
rimasta senza apporto si questa cosa
media saluto porto nola facciamo conto
ma non è paura né di oporto
tu hai scritto
spiegare allora un'altra perla è buy
ma io non so dove abiti ma lo scopro no
allora rivela leggo perché non la faccio
con le buone maniere si ottiene tutto
maniere disegna me maniere le maniche
c'è il coraggio
certo facile
ma di segno un vecchio maniero
giammarco air leonardo da vinci con
vecchio maniera potente andare al cuore
non si comanda no però per bella quella
frase cuore il vizio cuore non ha detto
il buon cuore cuore bravo
cuore allegro
cornice che tutti sti sinonimi de felice
e allegre conterno
cuor contento
fai cagare il sole il tempo col contesto
il cielo bravo il cielo riscalda e ce la
fa una cosa che può sembrare questa un
maniero
cosa fa la croce rossa aiuto bravo e
quindi che fa il cielo al cuore sereno
con tanto il cielo lo aiuta
non so nemmeno che è balut e non gioco
pechino express che cosa è buono e
ti fanno
ma perché è una cosa che per loro è
buonissima ed è
capito bostik agitano e
ci si può fidare di una persona che in
passato mi ha fatto soffrire molto
adesso salva cambiata totalmente la
famiglia nata cioè il lupo perde il pelo
ma non il vizio
io credo però che ci sia un bug io dico
questa ragazza è facilmente una persona
che ti ha fatto soffrire in passato per
l'improvviso cambia credo che ci siano
dei tempi un pochino come nel sesso i
refrattarietà cioè una volta raggiunto
l'orgasmo poi la fai più e poi magari
può riprendere ed era stata 6
ricominciano tipo in montagna alice è
finita
[Applauso]
certo non è la cosa finisce questo vuol
dire che contro di vivere se ti va di di
verterà no vi eviterà però occhio al
rombo titolo il mio problema
sentimentale entro le mani generale
tutti i ragazzi che mi piacciono ad un
certo punto si scopre che sono
innamorati della dinamica incontro che
io inizio a patire un po la cosa e non
avete tanta voglia di uscire con lei
però non è l'unica che ci sono passata
sono stata l'amica estroversa nella
coppia nonostante la mia amica mi
mancasse nulla assolutamente però si
deve amare questa cosa quindi non so che
consiglia tale perché sarei l'altra
quindi gli direi a carte al consiglio
importante cosa avresti voluto dire a
quella ragazza sveglia o quello che
diceva che non le mancava assolutamente
nulla e anche il fatto che spiegano
sempre che prima o poi arriverà una
persona che è semplicemente a cui non
piace roi oman è che uno piace a tutti
c'è perché sei estroversa allora piace a
tutti semplicemente si svolge sul
[ __ ] iniziamo a mettere sulla
bilancia i rapporti è più importante per
te la tua amicizia o piacere a un
ragazzo magari sei in un gruppo dei sei
di sé stessa ma è quello che gli piace
quindi che dei fatti legati dovresti
stare zitta per non piacere a quello
cioè il senso di assomigliare al collega
bisogno di una cosa se la sicilia torno
e quella che piace magari si sono
avvicinati a te sono solo per arriva
cecilia è
veramente
non mi servono per fare un paragone ti
posso fare un complimento la calcola che
al momento sei tra la generazione z
quella che più semplice non millennio no
questo è meglio da coccarda al cartello
scritto sei la meno generazione fan si
era più secondo me se un po una extra
generazionale
forse non da niente
questo teniamo a lui ama ed udinese
tagliate interessa tagliate io questi
questo caso è per questo che finire
questa puntata con questa con un
brindisi a
33 extra generazionali
la vita perché le tasse sono un numero
un numero numero a tre cifre nel tuo
caso
cecilia grazie di cuore a
volare noi ci vediamo non so quando ma
comunque sempre qui ciao ragazzi
[Musica]